naima is downsizing as a motor
downsizing
maintaining power with lower engine
displacement is an important topic in
car making says our car tester on
delayed cinema there are still skeptics
who think there is no substitute for
cubic capacity and that downsized
engines are closer to air pumps than
engines the cutting edge of downsizing
is currently a one-litre three-cylinder
engine and a turbocharger and that's the
engine in the premium compact car we'll
test drive today the Audi a3
passed us Ankush to them
there's nothing unusual about the engine
sound the 1.0 TFSI engine is part of the
a3 facelift counting the s-class model
the new a3 comes in nine different
engine variants the three cylinder with
85 kilowatts is the least powerful fuel
consumption is four and a half liters
per 100 kilometers so the three cylinder
is the 50th gasoline engine for the a3
up on Titan Andre says there's only one
way to see whether a three cylinder
engine is as bad as some say step on the
gas I won't as always well the
performance isn't exactly an adrenaline
rush but this isn't a sports car it's
the entry-level model and the power is
adequate for everyday use the three
cylinder a3 takes nearly ten seconds to
accelerate to 100 kilometers an hour the
shifting is done by an S tronic 7-speed
automatic our test car cost just over
26,000 euros in Germany
as a bamboo flooring Andre says you
might expect a three cylinder engine to
vibrate loudly but that's not the case
it's a bit rough when you accelerate but
it's surprisingly quiet when you cruise
along of course the engineers know what
weaknesses a three cylinder is prone to
and need to be counteracted Pathan Dre
sees no disadvantage in the missing four
cylinder John never kisses a patent [ __ ]
about it as well
you see that kind of knock Tyler in
Finland cylinder the revision of the a3
has changed some things inside and out
the package with a sat-nav and virtual
cockpit costs around three thousand
euros it presents all the important
information within the drivers site
additional assist systems are available
including the traffic jam assistant
the new light design of the exterior is
really eye-catching
matrix LED headlights are optional the
lower part of the bumper has also been
revised
alterations in the rear are more subtle
muscle indistinct the smaller engine
means less sportiness is Andre but the
rest of the car isn't slack the steering
is well adjusted and direct the
suspension is tight enough to take
curves fast and smoothly it fish for mr.
: fine come with the revised a3 out he
offers its customers more individual
choices many optional features for
example the matrix LED lights and the
three cylinder engine are new for Audi
compacts but not for compacts in general
opals current Astra for example already
offered them here howdy
is playing catch-up so what's my Andre
says the OD three cylinder engine works
fine it's not too loud and makes no dent
and driving comfort
it's not a fast accelerator and not
terribly sporty but Andre says if you're
worried about downsizing and
three-cylinder engines the best thing to
do is to take such a car out for a test
drive and see for yourself the
downsizing and Jiang's Ford right
cylinder motor all Diesel's manifest -
green diamonds lburrows phobia